the Harry Potter world may seem like a
wondrous Place filled with magic butter
beer and chocolate frogs but there are
still some pretty dark and twisted parts
to the stories the series may have been
kid-friendly at first but it quickly did
away with any age constraints to cast
its spell on Generations thanks in part
to some surprisingly grown-up elements
from suggestive names to infuriating
character choices here are some aspects
of the Harry Potter series that take on
a whole new meaning for adult audiences
negligence or abuse Dumbledore does a
great job of passing himself off as a
kindly benevolent Father Figure to Harry
and the rest of the student body but if
you take a close look at his actual
actions he's a pretty icy person who
knowingly sends children into Harm's Way
for the sake of an obscure prophecy and
his willingness to throw Harry to the
Wolves sometimes literally speaking is
just part of the series troubling trend
of adults being negligent or even
possibly abusive to these kids Hagrid
regularly writes out road maps for the
main Trio to waltz into danger
I shouldn't have said that I should not
have said that the faculty is filled
with crazy people and even the parents
are pretty lousy how else could you
explain Hermione's folks who are Muggles
allowing their 11 year old to run
through a wall and hop on a train they
never even saw or how no one bothered to
check on baby Harry Potter for a decade
after he was dropped off at the doorstep
of an aunt knuckle everyone knew were
terrible good adulting everybody
the ministry of what there are tons of
pseudo-political commentaries contained
in the Harry Potter series Gellert
Grindelwald tries to enslave the Mughal
population by way of a global Wizarding
war that not coincidentally rages
alongside the real-life events of World
War II Voldemort and his Death Eaters
fight for genetic Supremacy over
half-bloods and Muggles like some of the
worst villains in history but perhaps
the most unsettling aspect of the
stories is that the ministry of magic
remains in place without any checks or
balances and seems to oppress certain
classes of wizards they have a
totalitarian approach to Justice with
boundary-free surveillance options at
their disposal and an army of souls
sucking Dementors who inflict cruel
punishment on prisoners they're also in
charge of all the money and sometimes
distribute assets unfairly between
various families it just goes to show
that even at its best The Wizarding
World is never truly free just ask the
house elves
fat chaming it gets a laugh out of a lot
of readers but the way JK Rowling writes
about Dudley dursley in the earliest
installments of the Harry Potter series
is kind of troubling
although she has plenty of faults to
choose from while writing about Harry's
spoiled cousin she pays a lot of
attention to the fact that he's poorly
or as she writes it the size of a young
killer whale descriptions of Dudley's
Piggly little eyes and his resemblance
to a pig in a wig red is especially
cruel and unnecessary in retrospect even
if Rowling has insisted she's against
fat shaming sexual innuendos the Harry
Potter books may be meant for kids but
certain parts belong in the Restricted
Section for example there is the
ingorgio spell which seems like a poor
choice of name on Rowling's part and is
probably the only explanation for how
Hagrid's father made Whoopi with a
giantess I shouldn't have said that I
should not have said that then there's
the fact that these are all teenage
students who've had no sex ed coursework
at all some have traced the timing of
nymphadora tonk's conception to her
parents teen years rolling herself has
said she didn't mean to encourage teen
pregnancy in the story but thanks to a
dirty Easter egg in the Marauders map
from the Prisoner of Azkaban movie we
know Hogwarts could get pretty steamy
with or without proper education about
safe sex
wasted gifts as creative and thorough as
rolling was when creating the
potterburst there are some aspects of
the stories that become pretty
frustrating in hindsight Snape has the
gift of legitimacy for example but
doesn't bother using it to figure out
that Barty Crouch Jr is drinking poly
juice potion to disguise himself as
mad-eye moody in the Goblet of Fire
seems like that might have been
important
foreign
's Time Turner a literal time travel
device could have been used for far more
important things in overloading her
school schedule and springing an animal
from execution Harry could have probably
used that luck potion he gets in
Half-Blood Prince to help him defeat
Voldemort and Minerva mcgonagall's
shape-shifting skills should have given
her an upper hand in undermining Dolores
Umbridge who just so happens to be a
sucker for cats and the consequences may
be severe instead all of these elements
just come and go as trivial moments of
convenience despite the fact that there
is an all-out war in motion and let's
not forget how casually Dumbledore gives
Harry one of the three sacred Deathly
Hollows the cloak of invisibility long
before he could come anywhere near
appreciating its true value
whoa
my Pony's gone perverted Poltergeist
Harry Potter fans might be inclined to
feel sorry for Moaning Myrtle since
she's obviously a sensitive person who
didn't deserve to die because such a
young age but that doesn't excuse her
posthumous perversions in the Goblet of
Fire she has a habit of sneaking in on
boys in the bathtub and spying on them
without their permission hello
long time Mercy
ah Stoner house house Hufflepuff boasted
some of the nicest and most Serene
students of the Hogwarts bunch and there
may have been a reason for the relaxed
attitudes not only does the name of
their house sound kind of like it
endorses huffing and puffing but
hufflepuffs tended to excel at herbology
love to laugh and lived right by the
kitchens coincidence
Weasley weirdos in the Prisoner of
Azkaban the dark lord sniveling sidekick
Peter Pettigrew is eventually spotted
Alive and Well on the Marauders map that
Fred and George Weasley have been
holding on to that's how he's ultimately
discovered to be disguised as Ronald's
pet rat but if he's always visible on
the map and the Weasley twins have full
access to it and in theory would check
in on their younger brother once in a
while they have to know he has
unexpected company in his room each
night and just ignore it you don't need
magic powers to see that's pretty messed
up
for millions of people around the globe
the Harry Potter book and film series
were the closest they'd ever come to
experiencing actual magic the Journey of
the young wizard from an orphan who
lived under the stairs at his cruel
aunt's home into the legendary hero who
defeated the world's darkest villain was
nothing short of Epic the final
installment of the story was as complex
as it needed to be to wrap up seven
chapters worth of sorcerer storytelling
so to make sure you caught everything
important at the end let's shed a little
lumos light on what happened in the
conclusion of the Harry Potter Saga
Wicked
Snape's true side comes through in the
beginning of the final film Dementors
loomed over Hogwarts Professor Snape
observed from on high how much
Devastation the Dark Lord's looming
presence had caused his school but he
had to carry on because it was all part
of the plan no one else knew about see
Snape might have seemed like a terrible
person throughout the whole series but
his true loyalties became clear in his
final moments he was ultimately expelled
from school and killed by Voldemort's
snake just so the dark lord could take
true ownership of the Elder Wand some
friend valdi was Harry overheard
everything and tried to rush in and help
Snape as soon as you know who was gone
but it was too late instead Snape used
his last moments to give his least
favorite student a teardrop full of
memories in them Harry discovered the
gut-wrenching backstory of Snape's
unrequited love for Harry's mother Lily
after all this time
[Music]
all the way as it turned out he'd been
crazy about her since childhood and was
also looking after Harry the whole time
by feigning allegiance to the dark lord
the only reason he murdered Dumbledore
was because the Headmaster was already
dying and didn't want Draco Malfoy to be
forced to do the deed Snape's opened
contempt for Harriet Hogwarts was still
pretty real since he looked so much like
his dad James but he was trying to
protect Harry all the while so he could
fulfill his Destiny to defeat the dark
lord it really didn't hurt Snape's
feelings too much that Harry Potter was
always meant to die in his big battle
with Voldemort though speaking of which
no Resurrection Stone required there's a
reason Dumbledore had his eye on Harry
Potter from day one and helped fan the
flames on Harry's Chosen One Persona in
The Wizarding Community he was one of
the few people who knew that Harry was
predestined to die in a battle against
Voldemort
you have
the Grim Harry finally realized the
truth about his fate once he saw Snape's
memories and found out he himself was
the final horcrux
Voldemort
lives inside him
after Helga hufflepuff's cup was
destroyed in the diadem of Rowena
Ravenclaw was done for Harry left
Hermione and Ron to deal with the snake
while he set off on what he knew was a
suicide mission to face Voldemort in the
Forbidden Forest sir when the time comes
the boy must die
yes he didn't exactly know what would
happen after that of course but he
trusted the late Headmaster enough to
follow his lead even to his own death if
necessary boy who lived
[Music]
come to die upon going gently into that
good night Harry awakened in what
appeared to be a milky white vision of
King's cross station where he'd hopped
onto platform nine and three quarters so
many times before Dumbledore awaited him
with the news that he'd successfully
killed off the part of Voldemort that
remained inside of him in the process of
dying so Harry had a choice to board a
train back to the realm of the living or
to just move on to where he didn't say
Harry knowing his battle wasn't done
opted for the former he left behind the
scaly tiny version of Voldemort that had
infected his mind for so long and used
his perceived death to gain an advantage
Haggard carried him back to the school
just as an unknowing Voldemort started
bragging about his Conquest to Garner
new recruits and got an unexpected
surprise the Elder Wand was his all
along no matter how many horcruxes Harry
and his friend successfully destroyed
Voldemort was still a more powerful
wizard than all of them so when Harry
arose from the dead to pick a final
fight with the Dark Lord he was very
quickly overtaken by you know who but
Voldemort still couldn't kill him with
the wand again even after he'd taken
ownership from Snape why well it turned
out that Snape wasn't the one who'd
gained control of the Elder Wand in the
first place so didn't actually pass to
Voldemort upon Snape's execution while
Snape had indeed killed Dumbledore and
taken possession of the wand in
Half-Blood Prince it was Draco who'd
originally disarmed Dumbledore and thus
received the allegiance of the Elder
Wand then when Harry disarmed him and
their subsequent duel it was Harry who'd
laid claim to the Elder Wand so while
the Elder Wand was successfully used to
strike its Master down in the forest
when Harry had surrendered himself to
the Dark Lord he still wasn't disarmed
of the wand in that battle it remained
loyal to Harry instead of Voldemort and
it wasn't the only magical instrument
that came into play to take all snake
face down a key weapon presented itself
The Sword of Gryffindor had been an
instrumental tool in destroying
horcruxes throughout Harry Potter lore
Dumbledore used it to destroy the gaunt
Family ring Harry retrieved it from the
frozen lake and Ron used it to destroy
the locket that was causing his buddy so
much mental anguish despite knowing its
powers Harry offered the sword to grip
hook in exchange for his help to get
them into belich tricks lestrange's
vaulted Gringotts grip hook returned to
villainy soon after though and left
Harry and his friends in the Lurch by
abandoning them in the vault Caverns
with no promise to get them out Hermione
always with a clever idea up her sleeve
led the trio to ride a dungeon-bound
dragon out of the bank with grip hook
perishing in the fiery Skirmish that
ensued
the sword then disappeared from his grip
to present itself to a more worthy Pair
of Hands later on when Hermione and Ron
were back at Hogwarts trying to learn
nagini away the sword presented itself
to Neville Longbottom so he could slice
the snake's head off and deal Voldemort
one last crucial blow as he fought his
ultimate battle with Harry unlike other
similar weapons in the Harry Potter
verse the sword knew no master and
simply shows whoever was worthiest at
the time and few were more worthy than
Neville people die every day
they didn't die in vain
but you will
the Elder Wand returned to Harry and
left Voldemort falling to pieces
literally the Deathly Hallows come
together at last there was an
interesting Easter egg contained in
Harry's first shot of the last film as
he mourned Dobby's beachfront grave he
looked in a triangular fragment of a
mirror the elf had possessed thanks to
the circular nature of his glasses it
created the symbol of the Deathly
Hallows and the reflection is a wink to
how all three elements would eventually
be his as explained in the tale of the
Three Brothers in the second to last
movie The Deathly Hallows consisted of
the Elder Wand the cloak of invisibility
and the resurrection Stone when combined
they gave a wizard Untold power the
ability to disappear from death's
purview and a means to bring back lost
souls Voldemort got his hands on one the
Elder Wand while Harry had been casually
given the cloak in his earliest days at
Hogwarts not knowing its strength he
eventually recovered the stone too after
kissing his snitch goodbye with the
intention of sacrificing himself unlike
Voldemort however Harry didn't aim to
use these items for world domination
once he came into possession of all
three instead he snapped the Elder Wand
in half and dropped the resurrection
Stone in the Forbidden Forest to be
trampled into the dirt by a centaur he
did keep the cloak for himself because
it had once belonged to his late father
and who'd give up an invisibility cloak
he'd later passed the cloak down to his
own son James Sirius Potter and James's
younger brother Albus Severus would
later swipe it in the events of the
cursed child speaking of which
the Next Generation in the 19 years
ahead epilogue to Deathly Hallows we met
Harry Potter's Trio of children with
Ginny Weasley particular attention was
paid to Albus Severus Potter his second
son as he prepared to board the Hogwarts
Express for his start at the school the
boy was contending with the possibility
that he might not make it into
Gryffindor and Harry consoled him as
best he could would you say that I am
and Slytherin house will have gained a
wonderful young wizard little did we
know at the time of this movie's release
but this was ushering in a new
generation of Wizarding Journeys which
plays out on the stage in Rowling's
Harry Potter and the cursed child
was it all in his head there's a popular
fan theory that everything that happened
to Harry Potter outside a privet Drive
was a mental making of his young abused
mind and Deathly Hallows did little to
dispel that theory in fact the movie
seemed to give a wink to that
possibility by having Harry ask his late
professor if his crazy adventure was all
just happening in his head of course
it's happening inside your head Harry
why should that mean
that it's not real so was the entirety
of the Harry Potter Universe fiction
coming from the imagination of a
desperate boy who lived under the stairs
and who wished for something more
actually if I think about it it doesn't
seem curious at all
the Harry Potter books and films have
been combed through by everyone who wish
they'd gotten a Hogwarts acceptance
letter on their 11th birthdays but there
are some details in the movies that only
Die Hard Potter fans could really pluck
out here are some Harry Potter Easter
eggs that only bona fide members of
Dumbledore's Army would have caught
Snape's coded message it took a long
time for Harry Potter to figure out that
Professor Snape wasn't actually out to
get him and make his stay at Hogwarts
miserable if he was a star student of
language like his pal Hermione though he
might have been able to unlock the
Half-Blood Prince's true intentions long
before he got a screening of Snape's
memories through Dumbledore's pin sieve
in the final chapter in The Sorcerer's
Stone Snape challenges Harry tell me
what would I get if I added powdered
root of acidol to an infusion of
wormwood
the moment seems like a check on Harry's
sudden star status is the Big Man on
Campus but in retrospect super fans have
always found a little more weight to
those words see as badel is actually a
member of the lily family and can invoke
the phrase my regrets follow you to your
grave meanwhile wormwood is literally
defined as something bitter or Grievous
this has led many to believe that Snape
was really just telling Mr Potter that
he was bitterly regretful of his mother
Lily passing away given the fact that he
loved her most of his life and clutched
her corpse in agony the day he
discovered the boy who lived that makes
a lot of sense then doesn't it so much
seven Harry Potter's number on the
Gryffindor Quidditch team is seven and
it's no accident he's the seventh of
Voldemort's horcruxes after all and
there are seven books in the series so
the filmmakers went to painstaking
efforts to include the fabled numerology
throughout the series whether you
noticed it or not there are a ton of
things that just so happen to add up to
seven throughout the movies like the
head count of snakes that line the door
to the Chamber of Secrets the number of
players on each Quidditch team the
number of children in the Weasley family
and the number of Harry Potters that are
made from the Order of the Phoenix to
disguise the real deal looks like seven
really was Harry's lucky number
Deathly Hollows everywhere speaking of
visual iconography the movies also made
a point of flashing the sign of the
Deathly Hollows during pivotal scenes as
well for example in the Goblet of Fire
Dumbledore gazes upon his collection of
artifacts in his office and they're
arranged in such a way to give us a wink
to the triangle Circle Line symbol that
would represent the cloak of
invisibility the resurrection Stone and
the Elder Wand later on in the story
another example comes in Deathly Hallows
Part 2 when Harry feeling bad about
Dobby's death looks in The Shard of
mirror the house elf had in his
possession the lens of his glasses and a
streak of glare create the symbol for a
split second as well seemingly reminding
him of his mission to destroy
Voldemort's horcruxes fans could launch
a full-scale Easter egg hunt to find all
the other nods to this Paramount piece
of symbolism because it's scattered
throughout the film series in small
moments such as these trelawny's
prophecies
Hermione Granger didn't care much for
divination but Professor trelawny's
prophecies did turn out to be
astonishingly accurate even when she
seemed her kookiest the one that most
people point to is prescient in
retrospect is from the books at one
point she declined a dinner invitation
and Prisoner of Azkaban because 12
people were already seated and 13 is
unlucky the theory was that the first
person to rise from a table of 13 would
be the first to die and as fate would
have it Sirius Black stood first from a
table of such number in Harry Potter and
the Order of the Phoenix yes he died
first but it takes an especially Keen
sensibility to Fair it out that her
birthday Claim about Harry was also
ultimately on point even though it
seemed way off at the time in the same
chapter of Prisoner of Azkaban she said
she thought he was born in mid-winter
but he answered that his birthday was
actually in July however Voldemort's
birthday was New Year's Eve and since
Harry had a piece of Voldemort lodged in
his soul after survive driving the
attack on his family well she was kind
of right then wasn't she plus of course
she totally called it when she said the
one with the power to Vanquish the dark
lord approaches born to those who have
Thrice defied him born as the seventh
month dies and the Dark Lord will Mark
him as his equal but he will have power
the Dark Lord knows not and neither must
die at the hand of the other for neither
can live while the other survives
have I said something
the chocolate frog bookend there is a
small wing to Harry's first journey on
the Hogwarts Express contained in the
very last scene of Deathly Hallows Part
2. during Harry's first ride when he
initially befriended Ron Weasley he used
his new pocket full of gringet scallions
to buy the lot of treats on the trolley
it didn't take long for he and Ron to
stuff their faces with all the Bewitched
goodies they could stomach one of the
chocolate frogs however got away and
hopped through the window which wasn't
so much of a problem for Ron since he
was more interested in collecting the
character cards that came with them
anyway in the final film as Harry and
Jenny's children board the same train
with Ron and Hermione's kids the
chocolate frog returns to the window as
a nod to the start of a new story this
time with boy wizard Albus Severus
Potter unknowingly beginning his journey
as the cursed child Voldemort was in
Hogwarts the whole time in the film
version of Prisoner of Azkaban there's a
moment when the students are walking
through the staircase with an
unexpectedly familiar face pops up in a
portrait Lord Voldemort it's a blurred
and fairly quick pass by situation but
that's got to be him a Nosferatu like
bald wizard in flowing black capes
reaching out to the students that pass
by him in his menacing way if it seems
odd that Voldemort's portrait would be
included in the halls of Hogwarts that's
because it is odd Not only was he dubbed
He Who Shall Not Be Named by everyone
and kept far far away from the
mainstream Wizarding Community but Ray
fines hadn't yet arrived as the
character it'd be a whole nother
installment the Goblet of Fire before
he'd show up foreshadowing much
dial 62442 for magic in the Order of the
Phoenix Harry is called to the ministry
of magic to have a disciplinary hearing
before the wizagomon after producing his
Patronus to save himself and his cousin
Dudley from a dementor while in the
Muggle realm Mr Weasley accompanies
Harry to the hearing and takes Harry
into a telephone box to get access to
the ministry in the book he narrates the
number he's dialing to get through as
6-2-442 on a traditional telephone like
that one the letters would be arranged
on the keypad as well and those digits
just so happen to spell magic there's no
chance that was a coincidence hedwig's
theme the score to the Harry Potter film
series has become quite an ear worm
since the films were released
unmistakably belonging to the series
forevermore the introductory music has
been titled hedwig's theme but the
character who actually played the music
during the movie was Hagrid in the first
film he plays the melody on his flute as
Harry Ron and Hermione all Rush up to
him for critical information on their
latest me ganderings around the school
grounds maybe it should have been called
Hagrid's theme instead aberforth's bar
there's a scene in the Order of the
Phoenix when Harry Ron and Hermione duck
out of Hogwarts to formulate
Dumbledore's Army at hogsmeade when they
hit up the hogshead a local bar for some
private planning they find that there's
just one other person there a bartender
lurking in the dark and he's got a goat
only JK Rowling's most faithful D.A
members would have recognized that this
was an early glimpse of Albus
Dumbledore's brother aberforth who is
obsessed with goats and owned a bar that
establishment would later come into play
again in Deathly Hallows Part 2 when the
trio tries to sneak back into Hogwarts
during another Troublesome Headmaster
Switcheroo moment this time with
aberforth arriving to lend a hand
opening at the close
there's a lot that can be read into the
snitches inscription that so famously
read I open at the close the most
obvious interpretation is that when
Harry kisses it in the Deathly Hallows
it opens itself up to present him with
the resurrection Stone so he can have a
pep talk with his long-lost loved ones
before sacrificing himself to Voldemort
to fulfill his part of the prophecy he
got it in the first book when he started
this journey and it opened at the close
simple enough right what should really
get the eyebrows raising though is the
fact that Rowling published the first
book back in 1997 when the events of
Deathly Hallows took place so it's also
a statement that symbolizes the entire
franchise as a whole it literally opens
at the close
is this all in Harry's head one of the
grimmest fan theories associated with
the Harry Potter books and films is the
idea that everything magical about
Harry's life outside of four privet
Drive was just a cruel fiction of his
overactive imagination the idea behind
this one is that Harry who was a
tortured orphan and was made to live in
the closet under the stairs by his cruel
aunt and uncle created this fictional
reality as a coping mechanism for his
circumstances and in the final
installment there is a momentary wink to
that very possibility and a possible
acknowledgment that it might be right on
the money after all after Harry has died
by Voldemort's wand and wakes up in a
dreamy version of King's cross station
he meets with Dumbledore who gives him
the option to stay in the living realm
or go into the Beyond Harry asks
Dumbledore if this is in his head and
Dumbledore answers like so is this all
real or is it just happening inside my
head of course it's happening inside
your head Harry why should that mean
that it's not real to fans looking for
confirmation of that theory there's
really only one possible response I'm
bloody hell
not every Harry Potter star made it
through all eight movies a few of them
were switched out for a wide range of
reasons including death run-ins with the
law and embarrassing scandals here are
some of the major Harry Potter
characters who were ultimately recast
between films and the stories of how
those transfigurations came to be
although there's still plenty of Potter
fans who prefer Richard Harris's
depiction of Dumbledore the role was
nonetheless Precast ahead of Harry
Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban after
the two-time Oscar winner passed away in
2002 from Hodgkin's Disease Harris had
expected that he might not be able to
carry on in the role forever which he
first took to please his granddaughter
he told the press that I'll keep doing
it as long as I enjoy it my help holds
out and they still want me but the
chances of all three of those factors
remaining constant are pretty slim the
part would eventually go to Michael
gambin who starred in all six following
films but gambin wasn't the only British
star invited to Don the heaping wig and
decadent cloaks years after the fact sir
Ian McKellen revealed that he too had a
shot at becoming Albus Dumbledore but
turned it down I I couldn't I I couldn't
take over the part from an actor who I'd
known didn't approve of Harris had
reportedly been unimpressed with
McKellen's career implying that he was a
passionless actor despite all this
McKellen added that he sometimes saw
himself on posters which featured gambin
as Dumbledore when Lord Voldemort first
appeared on screen in Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone there wasn't a lot
for the actor portraying him to do after
all he was mostly hidden behind
Professor Quarles turban throughout the
story and even when he did emerge his
face was superimposed on the back of
Quarles skull Richard Bremer did what he
could with the role but wasn't surprised
when he wasn't invited back to reprise
his part in Harry Potter and the Goblet
of Fire Brimmer told this is Northeast
The Producers spent a long time fighting
to get me so I'm very proud to have been
the first but the role is now being
played by rape finds who's an old mate
in the fourth film I've been in the
business a long time and it didn't
surprise me that they went for a bigger
name being hollywood-led and I'm happy
to pass it on to Rafe fines was already
an a-lister by the time Sorcerer's Stone
was was released having won Oscar
nominations for Schindler's List and The
English Patient so it's no surprise that
the filmmakers didn't seek him out for
that brief CGI appearance Jaime whalet
did an apt enough job as Draco Malfoy's
pastry loving henchman Vincent Crabb
like many of his contemporaries in the
series the young actor was completely
new to the world of film when he suited
up as the Slytherin sycophant but was
gradually given more and more screen
time throughout his sixth film tenure by
the time Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows arrived however grabs other half
Gregory Goyle was seen standing next to
a new Malfoy Lieutenant Blaise zabini
crab was completely out of the picture
and while the role itself wasn't recast
the character was shuffled out of sight
to make room for zabini this all stemmed
from whalet's off-camera run-ins with
the law whalet was arrested in 2009
after he was caught growing marijuana
plants in his mother's home that
incident alone was enough to lose him
his prime position in the Potter world
and the troubles would only continue
from there the actor was later arrested
again in 2012 for participating in a
riot and this time he faced jail
whalet's co-star Jessie cave would later
publicly rise to his defense but the
damage was still done and the actor
hasn't worked on a film since when the
Gryffindor common room portrait known as
the fat lady first appeared in Harry
Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone it was
celebrated actress Elizabeth Spriggs who
portrayed her however spriggs's
portrayal was brief and rather rigid in
blithely asking for the prefix password
so before the character would return in
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban
the actress was replaced with Don French
French brought a more comedic element to
the character as she desperately tries
to impress the Hogwarts student body
with her glass breaking operatic skills
[Applause]
[Applause]
French earned the role after her Harry
Potter spoof for charity caught the
attention of director and producer
Christopher Columbus told the BBC I
think she's incredibly funny and her
Harry Potter spoof for comic relief was
pretty amazing the casting of the Harry
Potter films was entirely limited to
British thespians a rule so strict it
even forced producers to turn down Robin
Williams for the role of Hagrid but Vern
Troyer became the rare exception when he
was cast as gringott's Banker grip hook
in Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone
Troyer was the only American actor with
a major role in the film but the
character was voiced by his English
co-star Warwick Davis who also portrayed
Professor Flitwick and another bank
teller in the film but by the time grip
hook became more significant to the
story in Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows Davis had taken over the role
completely grip poop has so much more
depth to him that honor ever been able
to get into my work as Professor
Flitwick and so I went in and read for
David Yates though it was was never
reported as the reason for troyo's
replacement the actor had been caught up
in a number of embarrassing scandals
following the first film's release
Harry Potter fans have spent countless
hours mulling over the books in the film
franchise and have devised some pretty
spellbinding theories about the world of
Witchcraft and Wizardry some of which
have even impressed the author herself
let's take a look at some of the most
game-changing of them all Muggles versus
Wizards why do wizards have to hide
their powers from Muggles and if they
are so powerful why aren't they in
charge of the world if history has
taught us anything it's that usually
those with Superior Firepower and
knowledge win in any matchup however one
redditor had a different idea and it
gives an interesting alternate
explanation Wizards and Muggles fought a
war sometime in the Middle Ages and the
Muggles won in Goblet of Fire it is
revealed that the ministry of magic has
to talk to the British prime minister
about bringing a dragon into the country
this implies that the minister of magic
reports to the British prime minister
and may require his approval for matters
of this nature additionally wizards of
today appear to be much less powerful
when compared to ancient Wizards like
Merlin the peverals and the founders of
Hogwarts perhaps the Muggles were more
successful with their trials and
inquisitions than we were originally led
to believe
the real Rita Skeeter there were a lot
of colorful characters to come and go in
the Harry Potter series but none felt
quite as familiar as Rita Skeeter the
Intrepid journalist who would stop at
nothing to get her scoop for the daily
Prophet while her ethics were often
questionable there was something about
her prose that made many fans wonder
whether JK Rowling might have designed
the character to be reminiscent of
herself after all Rowling is also a
writer who also made a detailed
accounting of the non-muggle world that
feels very very real to some readers at
least one theorist has taken it a step
further and suggested that rolling
actually is Rita Skeeter in real life
spilling all of these well-documented
details about the Wizarding World to us
no match types as a means of getting
revenge against those who shunned her
from the other side
scratch that last
The Secret of horcruxes one process that
never gets fully explained in the Harry
Potter series is how horcruxes are made
Lord Voldemort was able to make himself
a bounty of these little life preservers
at some point in his younger years but
he seemed to be the only one who ever
had any backup souls to spare and seemed
to be unable or unwilling to create any
more once our heroes started destroying
them so it must have been difficult but
this is very dark stuff very dark indeed
JK Rowling herself has been vague about
how they're made though she did once say
that attempts would probably be deadly
for most Wizards because it's as
complicated as splitting an atom
according to the Harry Potter World UK
on Twitter Rowling revealed the process
to her editor who allegedly felt like
vomiting after this led one redditor to
surmise that cannibalism may be involved
both cannibalism and the creation of
horcruxes involve stealing a life force
for the absorption of another the theory
seems to have gained some serious
traction and Fantastic Beasts the crimes
of Grindelwald
as it was revealed that prior to
becoming Voldemort's pet and tag along
horcrux nagini was actually a
shape-shifting maledictus who had a
female human form before we met her in
the original series Voldemort may have
killed off the piece of nagini that was
human and swapped in a piece of his own
soul instead in defense of the dursleys
when Voldemort tried to kill infant
Harry a small piece of Tom Riddle's Soul
latched onto Harry's brain and cozied up
in there for the next 17 years even
though Harry was not a traditional
horcrux we know that Voldemort's
presence affected Harry giving him some
of Voldemort's powers and causing
occasional angry and violent outbursts
what if Harry wasn't the only one
affected by Voldemort's presence
Voldemort's horcruxes were capable of
dramatically changing the personality of
someone exposed to one for extended
periods Harry and Hermione were
frequently snappish and angry while
carrying the locket and normally
happy-go-lucky Ron turned into a raging
jealous mess who abandoned and his
friends if a horcrux can do that to a
genial and good-natured person what
might it have done to the dursleys who
are around Harry every day for 10 years
from the flashbacks we know that petunia
wasn't exactly a very nice person as a
child and Vernon was probably no better
but it is interesting to consider that
maybe their already sour Natures were
further exacerbated by Voldemort's evil
influence since Dudley was born the same
year as Harry he's literally lived
almost his entire life around this
horcrux it almost makes you feel a
little sorry for them almost
cousin
Neville's clumsiness
during Neville Longbottom's first flying
lesson at Hogwarts he earned a
reputation as clumsy and perhaps not the
brightest student in the new class of
First Years there are plenty of other
examples of Neville being clumsy with
magic and spells during his early years
at the school but that first flying
lesson may not have been Neville's fault
at all after Voldemort's death the long
bottoms were targeted by Death Eaters
and tortured to Insanity which speaks to
a definite animus against the long
bottoms by Voldemort's crew when
Professor Quirrell first tries to kill
Harry and Sorcerer's Stone he does so by
bewitching Harry's broom as he rides it
during a quidditch match the unnatural
movements of Harry's broom are very
similar to what happened to Neville
during his flying lesson what if that
arm breaking incident was because quiro
was using the same charm to exact a
little torture on the long bottom boy it
should also be pointed out that until it
was broken during the events in order of
the Phoenix Neville was using his
father's wand the father who was driven
insane when Neville was an infant as we
all know the wand chooses the wizard and
so some of Neville's early difficulties
with spells may have been due to him
using this hand-me-down after Neville
gets a new wand he seems to grow in
Leaps and Bounds in his confidence and
spell abilities
self-sorting Wizards in Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone the Sorting Hat
struggles with where to put Potter after
the boy wizard kept thinking over and
over again
are in
no not Slytherin eh the Sorting Hat
assured him that it'd be a good fit for
him but sent him over to Gryffindor
instead for his wishes as a result of
that scene some fans suspect that Harry
may not have been the only one who Moved
himself to another house one fan Theory
suggests that both Ron and Hermione were
also sent to Gryffindor rather than
houses they were suited for Hufflepuff
and Ravenclaw respectively because of
their own preferences for Ron the
reasoning behind the choice seems simple
enough all of his family was already in
Gryffindor so he wanted to fit in for
Hermione it may have been a reflection
of her own Newfound Valor in venturing
into this whole new world alone
centaurs know all
there were two big scenes in the Harry
Potter series that pitted the titular
wizard against his arch nemesis
Voldemort in the Forbidden Forest and
the first may have foreshadowed the last
as one fan theorist points out after his
brush with death as a baby Harry's first
encounter with the dark lord took place
in the forest where he was sent to
detention alongside Hermione Ron and
Draco Malfoy with instructions to find
out who was killing off the unicorns
there he found a cloaked figure which
he'd later discovered to be Voldemort
drinking a unicorn's blood forens the
Centaur scared the figure away and in
the book was then scolded by his fellow
Centaur Bane who warned him we are sworn
not to set ourselves against the heavens
have we not read what is to come in the
movements of the planets the centaurs
didn't go on to spell it out so what we
didn't know at the time was that Harry's
fate was to die at the hands of
Voldemort in that very place the
centaurs pretty much foretold the final
battle before Harry knew the identity of
the cloaked figure that threat his life
so early on just something to think
about
protecting Snape the defense against the
dark arts classroom was a revolving door
for professors at Hogwarts during
Harry's time as a student first there
was Professor quarrel who carried
Voldemort on the back of his head then
came gilderoy Lockhart who was a fraud
and lost all his memories due to a
misfired memory charm Remus Lupine also
walked away after he was exposed as a
werewolf then Mad Eye Moody turned out
to be Barty Crouch Jr in Disguise and
Dolores Umbridge got herself dismissed
for insubordination and general
wickedness before Severus Snape was
finally transferred from his position as
potions Professor to take over
I really hate children all the while
Snape seemed like the most obvious
choice for the role and some fans were
left to wonder why he didn't get it
until Harry Potter and the Half-Blood
Prince
one theory has is that the Dumbledore
never gave him the post to protect him
the idea is that because he wouldn't let
Tom Riddle have the job years before
riddle cursed a position and assured
that everyone who occupied it would
suffer some kind of cruel fate and serve
just one year Dumbledore refused to nape
the job until he made the unbreakable
vow to kill Dumbledore and thus resigned
himself to a horrible year already the
theory might also explain why Snape as
Headmaster installed a Death Eater in
the role next as he was clearly willing
to sabotage the guy on the sly whenever
possible are you incapable of
restraining yourself or do you take
pride in being an insufferable
know-it-all Professor trelawny was the
real deal she might have caught a lot of
flack for her histrionics but Professor
trelawny was actually on the mark with
her prophecies a lot more often than
people thought for example a reread of
what she predicted in Harry Potter and
the Prisoner of Azkaban has some
theorists believing she predicted
Dumbledore's death long before it
happened because she refused to see the
Christmas dinner by saying if I joined
the table we shall be 13 nothing could
be more unlucky never forget that when
13 dined together the first to rise will
be the first to die with Peter Pettigrew
hiding out in the form of Ron's rat
scabbers there were 13 people at the
table and Dumbledore was the first to
stand meanwhile she might not have been
so wrong in Harry Potter and the Goblet
of Fire when she sensed that Harry was
born in mid-winter Carrie was a July
baby but what we didn't know at the time
was that a piece of Voldemort was still
embedded in him and Tom Riddle's
birthday just so happened to be December
31st some speculate late that her
misinterpretation may have only been due
to the fact that her sense was so strong
that she was picking up on the Dark
Lord's date of birth instead it looks
like sebel trelawny shouldn't have been
such a laughingstock after all
actress Shirley Henderson has a career
that spans well beyond a bathroom at
Hogwarts and today we're going to find
out what she's been doing since her
stint in Harry Potter from Korean films
to acclaimed biopics here's what
happened to the actress who played
Moaning Myrtle who's Moaning Myrtle I'm
moaning model when you re-watch the
eight epic Harry Potter films it
probably seems like every single actor
in the United Kingdom was in the cast
including Shirley Henderson she
officially joined the series in its
second outing 2002's Harry Potter and
the Chamber of Secrets as the ghost
known as Moaning Myrtle despite having
roles in previous box office hits like
the romantic comedy Bridget Jones diary
and director Danny Boyle's breakthrough
film Trainspotting Chamber of Secrets is
the movie that really put Henderson on
the map and in the toilet Moaning Myrtle
who died at Hogwarts years before Harry
started school still haunts the bathroom
where she died exacting revenge on
school bullies whenever she can find
time to take a break from Sabe despite
her difficult nature she actually proves
useful during her interactions with
Harry in Chamber of Secrets Harry
eventually discovers that the mythical
monster of Slytherin house is living in
a hidden chamber directly beneath
Myrtle's bathroom and in Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire she assists Harry
as he tries to decipher one of his tasks
for the tri-wizard tournament even
though she does so while spying on the
14 year old while he takes a bath
a long time no see
ah oh
perhaps the strangest part of
Henderson's Potter roll is that she was
37 years old when she first played the
ghost of Myrtle
immediately after exiting the Harry
Potter franchise in 2005 Shirley
Henderson found herself in a project fit
for royalty Sophia Coppola's avant-garde
Marie Antoinette
the 2006 film stars Kirsten Dunst as the
doomed queen of France who enjoys a life
of pure excess before meeting a
particularly grisly end during the
uprisings of the French Revolution the
film which won an Academy Award for best
costume design features Henderson as
Madame Sophie who was frequently at odds
with Marie Antoinette and constantly
plotting against the queen throughout
her Reign Madame Sophie might not have
been a leading role but it was an
important one proving that Henderson was
the perfect utility player in everything
from period pieces to Blockbusters
after working on many successful
theatrical releases Henderson joined the
streaming Revolution and took a pivotal
role in Netflix's Oak jaw
the film is about a young girl and a
Super Pig whose DNA has been modified to
make it a completely unique animal and
unfortunately a new food source
The Talented cast has huge Stars
including Tilda Swinton Jake Gyllenhaal
and Paul Dano and of course there's
Shirley Henderson in a literal
supporting role as the assistant to
swinton's flighty CEO Lucy mirando
besides being one of Netflix's most
critically praised films the movie gave
Henderson a chance to give a stellar
performance alongside Swinton even
though their characters look like
seriously bad people we don't look too
bad we don't
Shirley Henderson continued her strong
run in prestigious projects with 2018's
Stan and Ollie which stars Oscar nominee
John C Reilly as Oliver Hardy and Steve
Coogan as Stan Laurel the film tells the
story of the famed comedic Duo as they
struggle through personal and
professional problems near the end of
their careers
the roles of Laurel and Hardy's wives
required two talented actresses who
wouldn't be diminished to simple
background players
Stan and Ollie found that in Henderson
who plays Lucille Hardy and Nina Arianda
a Broadway star who plays Ida Laurel the
two actresses brilliantly stand out in
the film which isn't easy next to iconic
characters like Laurel and Hardy such a
wonderful reception it's okay
two double X for the price of one
clearly Shirley Henderson spent years
making a name for herself in big
International projects but she always
found time to return home and work in
highly regarded British television
dramas Henderson kicked off this trend
with 2013's South Cliff a crime drama
where she portrayed a woman in the midst
of a breakdown working alongside stars
like Game of Thrones Joe Dempsey and
black mirrors Rory Kinnear as
inhabitants of a small town grappling
with a series of violent shootings the
show was a huge success for Henderson
earning her a bafta nomination for the
role
continuing her pattern of choosing
intense characters Henderson took on a
supporting role in Happy Valley as an
unbalanced woman with a lot of Secrets
and apparently not a single umbrella in
an extremely unexpected reunion
Henderson appeared in Agatha Christie's
the ABC murders with none other than
Rupert Grint her old bathroom buddy from
Harry Potter and the Chamber of Secrets
but even after all these years she still
can't quite get her mind out of the
toilet I prefer my Gentleman to not be
Cavalier in their use of the lavatory
Pike it blocks up the pipes and then
he's got to get in there with a stick
and break it up
plenty of actors jump at the chance to
return to the films that first brought
them attention and Shirley Henderson is
no exception back in 1996 Henderson had
some very memorable scenes in the
original Trainspotting and in 2016 she
got the chance to reunite with all of
the main cast members for a sequel
Henderson reprized her role as Gail who
married her boyfriend Spud and had a
child with him however when Spud's
addiction problems take hold Gail and
her son leave him to figure out his own
recovery
Renton played by Ewan McGregor tries to
help Spud Channel his addictive nature
into a more positive direction with some
mixed results eventually Spud gets his
act together and helps financially
support Gail but it's with stolen money
as the film ends it seems like the two
might be heading toward a lasting
reunion although most of Henderson's
scenes are with Spud we can't help but
think that the actress formerly known as
Moaning Myrtle might have a few more
dirty secrets in common with you and
McGregor
throughout all eight of the Harry Potter
films viewers wondered when Ron Weasley
the affable jokester played by Rupert
Grint and Hermione Granger the super
smart Bookworm played by Emma Watson
would finally get together the question
was ultimately answered in the
franchise's final installment Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows part 2.
while their momentous kissing scene
changed from page to screen it wasn't
any less impactful in the moment but
Grant and Watson felt differently about
the onset experience both actors have
opened up about just how weird it was to
shoot this pivotal moment and they're
frequently joined by Harry Potter
himself played by Daniel Radcliffe who
also shared a kiss scene with Watson in
the films considering that Grant Watson
and Radcliffe grew up together after
joining the Blockbuster franchise while
they were still incredibly young it
makes sense that Grant would feel pretty
uncomfortable about kissing one of his
closest friends at the time much like
Ron Weasley Grint isn't one to mince
words about the entire experience during
a 2016 interview with people Grant
opened up about just how weird it was
for him to kiss Watson he said I never
looked back at that scene I've known
Emma since she was literally nine years
old and we had this very brother-sister
relationship and it just felt very
surreal I have a memory of her face
getting closer and closer like oh my God
I can't really remember anything apart
from that but Grant wasn't alone in
dreading Ron and Hermione's huge
climactic kiss Watson told movies
Ireland exactly why the kiss was so
awkward it's purely the fact that he's
like my brother and we were both totally
in the same boat I'm sure he will tell
you exactly the same thing it was very
strange and very weird believe me we
both wanted it to be over equally as
much as the other it's honestly like
kissing my brother it was weird and
Watson wasn't crazy about her kissing
scene with Radcliffe either she stated
with Harry I was half naked and covered
in silver paint so that was pretty
awkward in the end all three of them got
through it as Watson shared they were
both strange situations to be in but
both were complete gentlemen it's
obviously hard to put our personal
history to one side considering we grew
up together but once you've done it four
or five times it gets quite boring so it
definitely got easier
while Radcliffe was a gentleman
apparently Watson really went for it
while filming their kiss Radcliffe said
in an interview with MTV News I've just
been getting into so much trouble with
Emma about this because apparently I
said in an interview that she was like
an animal I thought it was going to be a
kind of a slow sensual thing and Emma
really went for it as fans know Harry
and Hermione don't actually kiss and
their entire romantic entanglement is a
vision produced by an evil magical
object known as a horcrux as a means to
torture Ron
Harry talks to sleep have you noticed
no of course not but that didn't change
how weird it was for everybody on set
Radcliffe echoed his friend's comments
stating it was kind of weird it is a bit
like kissing your sister I'm not
complaining it was good it was vigorous
for me I wasn't too freaked out but it's
a bigger deal for Emma I think it
generally is a bigger deal for girls oh
no no I mean she's brilliant and we're
friends but no as for Watson she was
apparently so embarrassed by the scene
that she made Grant who couldn't stop
laughing leave the set while Watson told
j14 that she was proud of the kiss
between Harry and Hermione Grant
remembers that he was kicked out of the
room when they were there actually
filming that kiss they did actually want
me there to kind of play off something
but I just found that too funny Emma
sent me out because I kept laughing it
just looked really strange
when rereading the Harry Potter books or
watching the movies it's hard not to
stumble upon little inconsistencies here
and there from limited career options to
the logistics of Polyjuice Potion these
are just a few Harry Potter details that
don't make sense
after a young Witcher wizard graduates
from Hogwarts they're expected to join
the adult Wizarding World and part of
that is figuring out which career works
for them during the fifth book in the
series order of the Phoenix how he
visits Professor McGonagall for a
required career advice meeting and they
discuss which classes Harry should take
to qualify for his desired post-grad job
however besides becoming an aura a dark
wizard catcher post Hogwarts options
seem pretty scarce especially according
to the adults in Harry's life it's never
revealed what Harry's parents James and
Lily did for a living but almost every
adult he knows growing up either works
for the Wizarding government the
ministry of magic or teachers at
Hogwarts though there is a Wizarding
Hospital Saint mungo's which is stucked
with healers and some talented athletes
might become quidditch players this
means there are roughly 4 viable career
paths in The Wizarding World the stage
play Harry Potter and the cursed child
which serves the sort of sequel to The
Original Series seems to confirm the
lack of career options as adults Harry
Ron and Hermione are all employed by the
ministry with her finally even serving a
term as a minister of magic
in Harry's third year at Hogwarts he
discovers the Marauders map an enchanted
moving map of Hogwarts that details
every secret passageway contains every
room and shows a user where every single
person within the castle is and whether
or not they're on the move a password
protected cheat sheet to the school the
map is immensely useful to Harry
throughout his time at Hogwarts and
Beyond and as it turns out it was his
Birthright all along Harry's Father
James helped create the map during his
own time there I solemnly swear that I
am up to no good
Harry has given the map by Ron's
Brothers Fred and George the notoriously
mischievous Weasley twins who have been
its custodians for years but this seems
a bit off considering that map
apparently contained a huge conspicuous
secret the entire time they had it Peter
Pettigrew one of the map's creators and
the man who betrayed Harry's parents
spent 12 years posing as Ron's pet rat
and sharing a dorm room with Ron and
Harry and apparently Fred and George
didn't pay much attention to the strange
name hanging out with their brother for
years the twins may be troublemakers but
they're not stupid it just doesn't add
up
one notable feature of Hogwarts is that
it's filled with magical moving
portraits and students and professors
alike can communicate with the seemingly
sentient subjects within from the
portrait of the fat lady who guards the
Gryffindor common room to the former
Headmasters and headmistresses living in
their own commemorative portraits and
Dumbledore's office this world is filled
with painted personalities who are fully
capable of carrying on conversations
with anyone who tries to talk to them
[Music]
though Harry never directly learns the
rules of portraits it seems as if
they're only created when a wizard dies
after Dumbledore's death in Half-Blood
Prince his portrait appears alongside
his predecessors and the headmaster's
office and as it turns out he dispense
his advice to Severus Snape who takes up
the post in the seventh book even so the
exact mechanics of these magical
portraits remain bafflingly unclear
there's definitely some part of the
person within the portraits but does it
only contain the knowledge they possess
until their death or can the portraits
continue to evolved
foreign
[Music]
how he encounters seems to be able to
process and learn new information making
the concept all the more confusing
naturally the magic behind this went
unexplained throughout the series
how he encounters plenty of action and
adventure during his time in Hogwarts
which seems par for the cause for a kid
constantly evading the most dangerous
dark wizard of all time as a result he
also encounters plenty of injuries from
regrowing all of the bones in his arms
recovering from deadly curses the
medical stuff for Hogwarts is usually on
high alert and the school nurse Madame
Pomfrey is capable of mending broken
bones on the blink of an eye but damn
palm free skills extend beyond life and
death circumstances as well when
Hermione ends up cursed with expanding
teeth the nurse shrinks them so that
they're cosmetically perfect even though
Hermione's teeth weren't perfect before
she was hit with a curse with that being
said it's a little odd that so many
characters in Harry's world including
Harry himself wear glasses if Madame
Pomfrey or any healer at Saint mongos
can cure poisoned snake bites and broken
legs why can't they fix something as
simple as a stigmatism one of the most
interesting potions in The Wizarding
World is poly juice potion a brew that
allows a user to transform into any
other person for one hour as long as I
have a bit of that person who which in
Harry's experience typically means a
hair or two from the person's head in
Harry's second year he and Ron
impersonate two Slytherin students crab
and goyal to figure out if Harry's
Nemesis Draco Malfoy is using the
Chamber of Secrets to attack muggle-born
students why are you wearing glasses
ah I'm reading reading
I don't know you could read then in
Harry's fourth year it turns out that
one of his professors is not the actual
Aura madai Moody but a Death Eater
pretending to be moody thanks to the
potion despite the difficult Brewing
process poly juice potion is a constant
Factor throughout Harry's Journey if
Folly juice potion seems too good to be
true you're right there are any number
of problems a user could encounter while
using it Beyond Hermione accidentally
using a cat hair in the Chamber of
Secrets and ending up in the hospital
Wing even if you look exactly like the
person you're impersonating anyone who
knows them well enough would likely
notice if your mannerisms are off the
entire situation could be blown wide
open when someone whose hair has been
used for Polyjuice suddenly doesn't
remember conversations or experiences
they had with other people Polly juice
might seem foolproof but it's far from
it you're lying Dolores
and one mustn't tell right
stupid
the Harry Potter films were perfectly
cast but it's still fun to look at what
might have been especially when it comes
to actors who decided to pass on the
chance to participate in such a huge
Blockbuster here are some actors who
decided that appearing in The Wizarding
franchise just wasn't for them
Ian McKellen is a legendary actor so it
makes sense that his name came up to
replace Richard Harris as Dumbledore in
the wake of Harris tragic death
following the second film however
McKellen turned down the role because he
thought it would have been inappropriate
as he explained people say to me don't
you wish you'd played Dumbledore I say
no I played Gandalf the original there
was a question as to whether I might
take over from Richard Harris but seeing
as one of the last things he did
publicly was say what a dreadful actor
he thought I was it would not have been
appropriate for me to take over his part
it would have been unfair she played
Dumbledore of course the wizard
I played the real wizard although
Michael Gambon eventually took over the
role for the rest of the series McKellen
still gets confused for the character he
told the telegraph in 2013. the other
day there were 100 people outside the
theater who wanted autographs just as I
did the last one a woman grasped my hand
and said it's so wonderful to meet
Dumbledore in person I blew her a kiss
and got into my car
Tilda Swinton was set to take on the
part of batty Professor Sybil treilani
but she ended up turning down the roll
at the time it was reported that she
couldn't fit the film into her busy
schedule however some comments she's
made since then imply that she may have
actually had a much weirder reason in a
2016 interview with Scott's magazine
Swinton condemned boarding schools
Hogwarts included she called her own
experience at West Heath boarding school
in London a quote very lonely and
isolating environment she further
explained that's why I dislike films
like Harry Potter which tend to
romanticize such places I think they are
a very cruel setting in which to grow up
and I don't feel children benefit from
that type of education children need
their parents and the love parents can
provide Emma Thompson ended up with the
part and Swinton avoided having to
relive any bad memories
Hugh Grant was reportedly so prepared to
play the role of pompous defense against
the dark arts Professor gilderoy
Lockhart in Harry Potter and the Chamber
of Secrets that he went ahead and dyed
his hair blonde however he ended up
backing out to star in the romantic
comedy two weeks notice however Chamber
of Secrets director Christopher Columbus
contested these reports claiming that he
had never spoken to the actor about
doing the film regardless of what Grant
was or wasn't offered the part ended up
going to Kenneth Branagh who brought his
standard level of Gusto to the
performance Pulp Fiction actor Tim Roth
was forced to decide between Tim
Burton's 2001 Planet of the Apes remake
and the part of Severus Snape in Harry
Potter according to Roth he was offered
the role before Alan Rickman was but he
decided to turn it down so that he could
focus on Apes as he told MTV News in
2007 I was going to do both films we
rigged it so that I could fly back and
forth they figured out the schedule but
it just got to be overwhelming in my
mind my kids really liked the books they
were really into me doing it but the
idea of being an ape with Tim was too
good while Rickman was ultimately
incredible in the role Roth might have
been closer to how the books originally
described Snape Rickman was old for the
part at 55 when the first film was
released while Roth was only 38 based on
the book Snape should have been 31 when
Harry started at Hogwarts according to
Roth he would have played Snape very
differently but he ultimately believed
Rickman was the right man for the role I
didn't want my life to be franchised
Helen mcrory didn't miss out on the
Harry Potter films entirely but she was
kept from playing a much bigger part
than what she ended up with mcrory
ultimately played Narcissa Malfoy though
she was originally cast as narcissus
sister Bellatrix Lestrange that role
eventually went to Helena Bonham Carter
when mcrory got pregnant
just a boy As mcrory Told parade in 2011
I got pregnant with my first child and
insurance wouldn't cover pregnant
witches it was lovely that they invited
me back and wanted me to be a part of it
somehow this begs the question what are
the maternity leave policies at Hogwarts
and the rest of the Wizarding World
fans started pushing for author JK
Rowling to appear in the Harry Potter
films as soon as they were announced but
the writer says she's better off behind
the camera Rowling told the Sunday mail
that producers offered her the chance to
play Harry's mom Lily but she ultimately
turned him down as she put it I really
am not cut out to be an actress even one
who just has to stand and wave I would
have messed it up somehow while
Geraldine Somerville did a great job as
Lily we're sure fans would have loved
rolling in the part too even if she did
mess it up it would have been a thrill
to see a beloved author do a cameo
[Music]
one of the most wicked teachers in the
history of Hogwarts Dolores sunbridge is
a fascinating villain and the woman who
played her Imelda Staunton is a
versatile and talented performer but
what happened to the actress after
leaving the franchise here's what
Staunton has been up to since Harry
Potter
Imelda stonson didn't join the Harry
Potter films until the fifth installment
the Order of the Phoenix but she was the
perfect choice to play the multi-layered
character of Dolores Umbridge as a new
defense against the dark arts instructor
a sakuran pink Club Professor is only
there to dissuade students from actually
learning this forces Harry and his
friends to create an illegal study group
so they can teach themselves defensive
spells if that wasn't bad enough
Umbridge also tortures our students and
in one scene she even gets a little slap
happy with Harry
despite the fact that she's driven out
of Hogwarts by the end of Harry's fifth
year Umbridge appears during the second
to last installment of the film series
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
part 1. in classic Umbridge style she's
back to her old ways of abusing power
fortunately Harry manages to disguise
himself and best her once again with a
mix of wholesomeness arrogance and
cruelty staunton's Pitch Perfect
performance as Umbridge left an
unforgettable mark on the series
after her run in the Harry Potter movies
it seemed logical for Stonington to
transition into other Blockbuster films
and eventually she found her way into a
few hugely successful Disney projects in
2010 Staunton joined Tim Burton's
adaptation of Lewis Carroll's classic
novel Alice in Wonderland the film even
features a few of storton's Harry Potter
co-stars including Alan Rickman Timothy
spall and Helena Bonham Carter as well
as staunton's husband Jim Carter she
only has a few short lines of the
talking flowers but Staunton gives her
thorny characters some serious
personality and she comes out smelling
like a rose stop that Staunton also
appeared in Disney's 2014 anti-hero tail
Maleficent which stars Angelina Jolie as
a seemingly evil witch who cursed Aurora
better known as Sleeping Beauty Staunton
plays a character named not grass she's
one of three Pixies who take human form
and stay by Aurora's side until she
becomes safer Maleficent's clutches
Staunton later reprized the role in the
2019 sequel Maleficent Mistress of evil
store to might not have physically
appeared on screen in her next big
project but her role was an incredibly
vital one in 2014's Paddington Staunton
provided the voice of Aunt Lucy who
remains off screen for most of the film
but still manages to give an emotional
backbone to the entire narrative
Paddington spends his childhood with his
loving Aunt Lucy and Uncle pastuzo who
was voiced by Michael Gambon you might
remember him as the actor who played
Albus Dumbledore opposite Staunton after
pastuzo tragically dies on Lucy sends
Paddington to live in London where he's
adopted by the quirky and kind Brown
family in Paddington 2 the little bear
embarked on a mission to bring Aunt Lucy
to London to live with him in the Browns
despite many struggles he eventually
succeeds and Staunton briefly reprises
her role for some of the film's most
heartfelt moments the same year that
stormten made her first appearance on
the Paddington series she took on an
emotionally charged and resonant project
called Pride the film based on a true
story is about a faction of London's
lgbtq plus community that bands together
to support miners at join the 1984
British miner strike though the two
groups seem to have very little in
common the lgbtq plus Community raises
money for the miners creating a campaign
known as lesbians and gays support the
miners Staunton played real life
activist hafina hidden who was part of
the women's support group and strike
committee throughout the film there's no
denying that Staunton gave a truly
powerful performance you better shut her
mouth or I'm gonna do it permanently
Staunton earned a bafta nomination for
best supporting actress and the film
itself got a nod at the Golden Globes
the best motion picture and the comedy
or musical category plus Pride featured
Staunton acting alongside yet another
Harry Potter veteran Bill Nighy who
appeared in the Deathly Hallows part 1.
after years on the big screen Staunton
took on some television roles but true
to form for The Talented actress she
wisely chose high-profile projects that
brought her even more Acclaim in 2007
and 2009 Staunton appeared in Cranford
and its sequel returned to Cranford the
story of a small town where widows and
the married women lead happy fulfilled
lives within their Community Comfort
featured Staunton as Octavia Paul one of
the more gossipy residents of the town
she was joined on the show by her
husband Jim Carter and once again her
old Harry Potter cohort Michael Gambon
the year 2012 brought storms an even
more critical success with HBO's
original film the girl which told the
dark lurid story of Alfred Hitchcock and
his enjoying obsession with the leading
lady of the birds Tippy headrun Staunton
played Alma Revel Hitchcock's
long-suffering wife and screenwriting
partner a performance earned her
nominations for another bafta and a
prime time Emmy Award
after the success of the original series
it seemed inevitable that Downton Abbey
would get its own movie and in 2019 the
long rumored film finally hit theaters
it focuses on a visit from King George V
to the Crawley estate Imelda staunton's
husband Jim Carter reprises his role as
Carson while she plays Maud one of Queen
Mary's ladies in Waiting the movie
premiered to positive reviews and it
also allowed Thornton to reunite with
her Potter co-star Maggie Smith who
played Professor McGonagall
are we going to kiss
glad you want to kiss me wasn't quite
what you said when I last heard from you
'd like to say dear oh there are several
things I would like to say
the actress who played the Laura
sunbridge isn't just an Acclaim star of
stage and screen in 2006 Imelda Staunton
made news when she was named an officer
of the order of the British Empire ten
years later she earned the title of
commander of the British Empire both
thanks to her work in the dramatic arts
now it seems that stortem will take her
royal Ambitions to the next level
according to Variety in the BBC Staunton
will play the part of Queen Elizabeth in
the fifth and final season of the crown
we can only be thankful that the Laura
Sun Bridge never achieved the power of
the throne
whatever happened to Madame Hooch Ron
Weasley's brother Charlie here's a look
at some of the many Harry Potter
storylines that just completely
disappeared from the films Madame Hooch
appears in Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone in a small but
significant moment for the boy who lived
played by Zoe Wanamaker Hogwarts
resident quidditch coach teaches flying
lessons to the first year students
Professor McGonagall observes Harry's
natural prowess in the air and gives him
a position as Seeker for gryffindor's
Quidditch team Madame Hooch can be seen
refereeing Harry's first match against
Slytherin where he almost swallows the
golden snitch and then that's the last
we ever see of her even though the
character continues throughout the books
why well actor Zoe Wanamaker only signed
on for one film which is likely why
Madame Hooch disappears from the story
after Sorcerer's Stone another character
to only feature in one film in the Harry
Potter series is gilderoy Lockhart
Harry's second defense against the dark
arts Professor is arguably his most
inept appearing in Harry Potter and the
Chamber of Secrets Lockhart is a
charismatic Charming celebrity renowned
for successfully banishing various dark
creatures but he's all style and no
substance his lessons at Hogwarts expose
him as a fraud and he admits at the end
of the film that he's taken credit for
other people's work throughout his
career Chamber of Secrets culminates
with a memory charm backfiring on
Lockhart thanks to Ron's broken wand
Lockhart gets a taste of his own
medicine losing all memory of who he is
and then you guessed it he disappears
for the rest of the movie series hello
who are you
from Weasley really
and uh who who am I in the books Harry
Ron and Hermione run into an amnesiac
Lockhart in Saint mungo's Hospital for
Magical maladies and injuries during
Harry Potter and the Order of the
Phoenix but actor Kenneth Brana likely
wasn't available to film this Cameo for
the movies
Sorcerer's Stone and Chamber of Secrets
includes several scenes showing Harry's
school lessons from Prisoner of Azkaban
onwards however Harry's classes take
more of a back seat in favor of the
growing drama at Hogwarts and Beyond the
boy Wizards lessons tend to appear only
when something significant happens
Harry's flight on Buckbeak in Prisoner
of Azkaban Moody explaining the
unforgivable curses in Goblet of Fire
Etc the books have more space to explore
Harry's Journey but in the films Harry
uses several spells seemingly out of the
blue with no prior classroom practice
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire is a
turning point in the story for
everyone's favorite teenage Trio Lord
Voldemort makes his comeback at last
emerging from a cauldron with no nose
and a thirst for blood while Harry Ron
and Hermione come of age as the series
takes a more dramatic adult tone but
it's not all bad for the golden Trio
especially Hermione who has a whirlwind
romance with quidditch sensation and
durmstrang student Victor from which
ends with crum asking Hermione to write
him after he leaves in the books this
happens but in the movies Crum is almost
entirely absent for the rest of the
series like Hermione Harry has a love
interest in Goblet of Fire Cho Chang who
initially rebuffs Harry for Cedric
Diggory after Cedric dies however Harry
grows close to Cho during Order of the
Phoenix Harry shares his first kiss with
Joe before their budding relationship
quickly goes awry when she spills the
beans to Dolores Umbridge about Harry's
secret group Dumbledore's Army Post
Order of the Phoenix Cho graduates from
Hogwarts and Harry pursues a
relationship with Ginny Weasley the two
are briefly reunited in Deathly Hallows
during the Prelude to the Battle of
Hogwarts the film follows a similar path
to the books here reducing Cho to a
cameo character after her abrupt breakup
with Harry
the Harry Potter films were mostly
faithful adaptations of the book series
though many characters had to be cut
during the jump from the page to the big
screen multiple members of Hogwarts
faculty never or barely appeared in the
films Professor bins Professor grubbly
plank plus most of the stuff with the
Centaur to name a few one teacher who
did have a cameo appearance before
disappearing from the film series is
professor sinistra sinistra teaches
astronomy lessons throughout Harry's
time at Hogwarts in the film she is
played by an unidentified actress in an
uncredited role which was later
retconned as Professor sinistra when the
actress's likeness was used in the Lego
Harry Potter video games omitting
Professor sinistra from the other Harry
Potter movies was a missed opportunity
for the series in regards to
representation the astronomy teacher's
physical appearance isn't given in the
books though the character was portrayed
by a black woman during Sorcerer's Stone
in hindsight the films could have
further developed sinistra as a
prominent POC character uh Colin cravy
equal parts in daring and annoying the
Starstruck student appears in Harry
Potter and the Chamber of Secrets as the
boy who lived's number one fan Colin is
one of the students to fall victim to
becoming petrified by the Basilisk
thankfully Harry Saves the Day by
venturing into the Chamber of Secrets to
rescue Ginny Weasley and kill the giant
snake Chamber of Secrets is the only
installment in the Harry Potter series
to Star Colin creevey in later films he
is replaced by an original character
called Nigel walpert Nigel can be seen
as an amalgam of Colin's character as
well as his brother Dennis who appears
in the books Nigel has a happier ending
in Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
Part 2 then his on-page counterpart in
the books Colin is killed by Death
Eaters during the Battle of Hogwarts it
seems that Colin's death was instead
given to Lavender Brown who in the films
is killed by fenrir greyback despite
surviving the battle in the books
Prisoner of Azkaban features some big
changes for Harry Ron and Hermione as
they face their third year at Hogwarts
new lessons are introduced such as
Professor trelawny's study of divination
and care of magical creatures classes
led by Hagrid both classes prove
difficult in different ways Harry rides
a hippogriff in his first lesson with
Hagrid while trelawny frequently
predicts Harry's imminent death after
seeing the Grim during a divination
class Buckbeak the hippogriff Harry
flies on plays a small but significant
role in the third installment Draco
Malfoy purposely provokes the Beast into
attacking him and Buckbeak is sentenced
to death thanks to draco's Father Lucius
thanks to the time Turner Harry and
Hermione managed to rescue Buckbeak
before his extermination Perry saves
Sirius Black from the Dementors before
his Godfather departs with the
hippogriff both of them fugitives from
the ministry of magic in the films
buckbeak's story ends there but in the
books there's a whole storyline with
Buckbeak that ends with a moving reunion
with Hagrid too bad we never saw it the
final installment in the Harry Potter
book gives fans their first look at
Albus Dumbledore's childhood and sub
sequent previously unknown history evil
journalist Rita Skeeter swoops in
shortly after Dumbledore's death to drag
the headmaster's name through the dirt
in her revealing biography the life and
lies of Albus Dumbledore when Harry
reads an excerpt in the daily Prophet it
triggers a crisis of Faith as he is
forced to confront the possibility that
he never knew his mentor's true nature
after all Skeeter's biography casts a
shadow on Dumbledore's Legacy but it
isn't necessarily untrue we learn in the
book that Dumbledore was involved with
the dark wizard Grindelwald as Harry
learns from Dumbledore's brother
aberforth aberforth explains that their
sister Ariana was attacked by three
muggle Boys in her youth causing her
magic to spiral out of control her
father Percival went after the Muggles
in retribution earning him a life
sentence in Azkaban and a sour
reputation for his family Ariana was
later left in albus's care after their
mother's death but she was killed
accidentally during a confrontation
between Albus and Grindelwald however
almost none of this is explained in the
film instead there's just a brief scene
that hints at these events events that
Harry explicitly isn't interested in at
all in the film
I'm not interested in what happened
between you and your brother
Ron's older brother Charlie has the
biggest blink and you'll miss it Cameo
appearance in the film series popping up
briefly in a photograph of the Weasley
family on their trip to Egypt in
Prisoner of Azkaban besides that Charlie
is an absent member of the Weasley Clan
never appearing properly on screen
though Ron mentions Charlie in Harry
Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone while
explaining that his brother works with
dragons in Romania
National Norwegian Ridgeback
my brother Charlie works at these in
Romania Charlie shows up a few times in
the books though the Wayward Weasley
takes Hagrid's baby dragon Norbert off
their hands in Sorcerer's Stone before
returning to Hogwarts and Goblet of Fire
as a Handler for the dragons used in the
tri-wizard tournament's first task like
the rest of his family Charlie is
present at the final battle against
Voldemort and Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows his exclusion from the
later movies suggests that his character
could have been retconned out of
existence to allow the film to focus on
portraying other Weasley siblings like
Ginny Bill and Fred and George in Goblet
of Fire Future Doctor Who star David
Tennant became one of the long list of
acclaimed British actors to feature in
the Harry Potter series playing the
villainous Barty Crouch Jr tenants role
in the film was altered from The Source
material in the books when Professor
Moody is revealed to actually be Barty
Crouch's son disguised via the power of
polyju's potion Barty Crouch Jr regales
Harry with an in-depth explanation of
how he was broken out of Azkaban by his
parents only to reunite with Voldemort
and help him enact his plan to capture
Harry barty's tale concludes with him
receiving the dementor's kiss for his
crimes the Revelation that Mad Eye Moody
is really Barty Crouch Jr is glossed
over pretty quickly in the film though
Crouch never explains his motivations or
receives the dementor's kiss Dumbledore
remarks that the Dementors will find
azkaban's missing prisoner and Crouch
promises that he will be welcomed back
like a hero did Crouch return to Azkaban
after that or did the Dementors perform
their soul-sealing kiss off screen it
isn't clear Crouch's storyline like
other characters in the films disappears
without closure or explanation
foreign